Welcome back everyone. It's April 28th
and we're in our discussion here for
fundamentals chapter 1 and appendix A.
And due to some intrafacilitator
discussions, Frasier and Andrew and I
have slightly amended the schedule and
the pace. This week we're just going to
discuss chapter 1, which is a relatively
theory light, math light, more thought
experiment, introductory chapter, and
appendix A on history.
And for following chapters and weeks, we
will
settle into a more relaxed two weeks per
chapter. It ramps up pretty fast and
intensively. So that should give us um a
good pace to
work through these chapters that have
sometimes several dozen formalisms.
give us also a little bit more time to
work on the code examples on the side.
So we'll of course continue updating
meetings is always going to be the
single source of truth and we'll see how
it goes with all these sessions. The
first week is going to be more about
like making sure all the figures and
stuff are entered and in and uh that
people have had the opportunity just to
be exposed and to write their questions.
And then in the second week for a given
chapter, we'll probably be more
revisiting and revising questions and
looking at some code examples or seeing
what else how people are kind of
vectoring off of the material.
Uh yeah, there's that interview with No
Way Out and with
>> Okay. And I added that to the resources
page.
So today we're going to discuss
chapter 1 and the appendix A
and I've brought in the figures for
those two sections. So we'll use the
figures to ground some of our discussion
and we can also look at the uh
questions.
And if you go to the chapter page like
chapter one on the top are the figures
and then we have the questions.
So um let us begin with the appendix a
little bit of history back to the
future. Um, so
that begins on page
and I'll bring up this first
figure that gives us a timeline
of the big picture. So just right off
the bat thinking about the history of
this field and all the world lines that
we've to bring us to this book in here.
Is there anything that anybody wants to
ask or just like add or remark about
from this figure or in their reading of
appendix A?
>> I would
just maybe ask her.
Um
>> yeah please
>> anyone if anyone is familiar with ET
Jane's work on I know that Frist has has
spoken about it in his discussions and
in his in the first book but uh I just
thought the absence of Jane's work on
basian brain here was for me
>> and maybe that would be a good point to
add in terms of anyone who's knew that
ET James um was talking about pacing and
brain back in 1860.
>> Yeah, I see basian brain here, but but
like you're saying it's not cited or
something.
>> Um,
yeah,
surely the basian began with at least in
the 60s.
>> Yeah, Andrew, that anyone else?
>> Oh, yeah. Just just quickly on that
point, I don't think James was the one
who actually used the phrase basian
brain. I think that's a slightly later
development because to to my knowledge,
James was predominantly a mathematician,
not a neuroscientist. And so Fristen
uses a lot of um sort of aspects that
bear on on physics and mathematics from
James and that includes things like the
the maximum entropy principle and then
then following that the maximum caliber
principle and it's the caliber one that
kind of turns it more into kind of like
a a view over paths. But yeah, I think
it's predominantly the mathematics
backing was coming from James among
among others. Yeah.
>> Yeah. The top of this is 1990 and so
diff different threads are going to
trace back to
decades to to hundreds of years earlier.
But I mean before looking at this
chapter like or after what is the
history of active inference? What are
the upstream dependencies
like what other traditions or what did
people think would be in this kind of a
history chapter
which kind of begins more qualitatively
but quickly dives into some formalism.
For example, I thought it was very
interesting that the um well, first on
the right side we have the development
of neuroiming
and Sanjieve does a great job of
connecting the dots with FE and with the
SPM package, the statistical parametric
mapping package.
which is a really great background
material to know and understand the
earlier SPM textbooks and the more
recent versions. It is neuroiming
focused. However, it is going to work
out a lot of the basic kind of two-part
hidden observable dynamical systems. You
have some latent neurodynamics that are
unobserved directly. And then you have
sensor fusion with neuroiming
modalities. Could have one EEG sensor.
You could have an MEG, fMRI. So you have
sensor fusion within and across
modalities of sensors
inferring causal latence unobserved
dynamics. That is all being developed in
the Phil. um imaging lab with Fristen at
all in the '9s. So I think on this right
side we have the injection of
essentially sensor fusion and latent
space inference and causal inference
methods. Then I found it quite
interesting that the blanket node if you
will and it is here is the 2003 theory
of cortical responses
rather than for example the 2005 2006 or
more ambitious
unified framework.
So there's obviously more nodes that you
can add onto this picture like upstream
dependencies and ontology terms and then
more downstream and things like that.
But this definitely grounds the work as
Christian and Nemoshi at all do in the
brain and in looking for this framework
to understand the cortical response
which is like to say the EEG response
when there's a mismatch surprise or what
is different with
different context or different
individuals in their cortical response
like if we want to have a framework
network that accounts for EEG data when
people are presented with a mismatch
tone. We need to have that sensor fusion
and latent space modeling down pat.
That's like kind of just operational and
empirical. And then you're going to
quickly run into oh what matters is not
just the incoming data but also the
prediction that the agent is making
about the data which is the famous row
and Ballard 1999
work on visual predictive coding which
is that you can account for certain
extraclass effects in visual
neuroscience by understanding the
predictions that the person is making or
that the animal is making about what
they expect to see. So just pretty
interesting to see how that gets
bottlenecked here through 2003.
Then there's kind of a dual channel
development.
On one hand, these successive phases of
the free energy principle which feed
back into basian mechanics more recently
and then we have a sort of continuous
state space and discrete state space
model
threads lineages which are represented
in separate chapters in the 2022
textbook and they're treated differently
here. And so
there's and there's a small typo there
with wage. So there's a lot of different
pieces here, but again, just kind of
looking at all these pieces on the table
here.
Okay. So I'm just going to copy the the
question out.
So here we go. So again, you could
follow the uh location
where where I'm at in KOD here.
So do cortical responses represent
predictions? What would anyone say to
that?
not simply predictions
but but the integrated outcome
of the the neural system
which is including it's prior's meeting
incoming observations
and then the idea is through signal
processing to isolate features of that
waveform that might represent prediction
or might represent a surprise
divergence.
But the waveform itself is the
integrated outcome of everything that's
happening which is part of the maddening
mystery of neuroiming
is so much is happening that there have
to be series of deconvolution techniques
and spectral analysis methods and
statistical testing to get at
differential activity in response to for
example a task.
Does anyone have another like just a a
section or a quote or a page in appendix
A
that they want to highlight or ask a
question about?
Just uh slightly backtracking to that
question you were looking at. Um I'll
try to find at least one paper that
relates to it but on cortical responses
representing predictions
um there was some really interesting
work and those who've worked with like
POMDP models or otherwise like being
able to simulate
uh local field potentials or LFPS with
those kinds of models. um the the kind
of framework that that's been used in
some papers including by Fristen and PAR
involve taking the the prediction errors
actually so not the prediction itself
but the prediction error and kind of
like what Daniel mentioned of like
divergence and and surprise um with the
whenever you plot the prediction errors
over time uh with within a single like
inference step it starts to resemble
like an LFP waveform and so Um that's
the sort of thing that can give you that
sort of extra step of trying to
empirically uh fit data or rather fit to
empirical data is to like have a look at
the waveform that is generated by the
prediction errors. Um so if if you're
willing to agree with that kind of
framework then then an EEG signal could
itself be um something like uh
prediction errors over over time. I
wouldn't I wouldn't say it's perfectly
one to one like that. It's still an
integrated thing like Daniel said, but
uh yeah, I'll uh have a look for that
for anyone who's interested.
Yeah. What's just a a I mean a a page or
a quote or an aspect of appendix A that
somebody was curious about?
Maybe just a a comment uh Daniel uh I
found the section on cybernetics and
control theory to be quite relevant
contextualizing chapter one. So you know
the cybernetics and control theory this
is a there's probably maybe some people
here who who know quite a lot about
that. That's one prior approach to
trying to account for what it is to be
an adaptive system, I suppose. And he
goes into talking about, you know, Conan
Ashby's good regulator theorem that for,
you know, any model to be a good
regulator of a system or for a
controller to be a good regulator of
that system, it has to be a good model
of that system. That very much is kind
of where chapter one starts. It starts
at this kind of discussion about the
modeling relation. like what is a model
and how does that relate to the system
that it is modeling and then from there
we you know he he bootstraps up the the
generative process and the generative
model which is just absolutely
foundational to understand one of the
things that really helped me when I was
kind of first trying to gro all of this
distinction between the generative model
generative process was the work of of
James and on the good regulator theorem
so just historically I found that
helpful uh for me at least
Cool. So, just like to sort of speedrun
this section headers in the appendix A
history and then we'll go to to one and
then that will um begin the more
uh beginning of the book type material.
It starts off in section A1 talking
about neuroiming which is both Fristen's
earlier career as well as the analytical
basis of these latent dynamic causal
modeling frameworks and the ability to
integrate empirical noisy sensor fusion
type approaches signal processing with
these more small parameter latent space
models. So it's kind of on a different
neighborhood than just scaling the
number of parameters within a
traditional neural network framework for
example. However, as we will see and
explore, neural networks can be very
easily slotted in to a variety of these
computations but in their essence they
can be framed as matrix operations. So
A1 takes us back to neuroiming, SPM and
earlier work. A12 goes into
representation learning which is another
way of talking about latent space
modeling and the role of basian updating
and variational methods in doing latent
space updating.
taking us through predictive processing,
predictive coding, basian brain, brain
inspired intelligence methods and how
that relate to a sort of integrated what
the 2022 book calls the whole iguana
approach to understanding the active
basian brain in terms of its inputs,
cognitive processes and outputs as
actions and cognitive processes being
like everything that a mind and brain
does. So attention, memory,
anticipation, all these affect all these
different kinds of features. And that's
the lumper splitter question. Are we
going to have like a special bespoke
model notation ontology field department
major for affect and memory and
anticipation or are we going to have a
big tense umbrella where we can use a
unifying approach to understanding
cognitive phenomena? And then as that
was being drawn out in the end of the
millennium and the early years of the
2000s, that's when it was like, oh,
there are fundamental connections with
more material thermodynamic processes.
That is what was the early 2000s
origination of the free energy principle
and leads to basian mechanics as a
fourth mechanic to round out the
classical mechanical, statistical,
thermodynamical
and quantum mechanical. Um A15
goes into A15 6 and 7 go into continuous
and discrete state space models which is
explored in the 2022 textbook and
several other places and then A2 goes
into the future. So A1 was the past
which is like there was in the
background and kind of on the um
hearkening the frontier was first
principles of physics-based intelligence
and then in terms of realizables there
was a dual channel development of
continuous and discrete state space type
models.
A2 is the future and we have deep
learning and generative models. We're
going to be talking about generative
models and we'll see some isomorphisms
and some tensions or differences with
how it's used in reference to like
generative AI.
A22 as Fasier noted is about cybernetics
and control theory and cognitive
modeling whole iguana modeling can be
understood of in a way as like the
inbound is signal processing and the
outbound is control theory and in
standalone control theory they often
leave apart or ignore the signal
processing aspect. And then in signal
processing, it's framed often as a
passive process and they leave out the
actionable side. So joint distributional
generative model cognitive modeling is
basically the totalistic consideration
of sensory states, internal cognitive
states, outgoing action states, and
external world states or generative
process states. So that's the four-fold
partition, the particular partition. And
that's kind of how these puzzle pieces
which were studied in a more domain
specific or restricted sense are brought
together in what's happening here. 823
goes into information theory which
underlies a variety of different
formalisms that are going to come up in
the book like entropy and a variety of
other things. Um
A24 goes into reinforcement learning.
There's been a massive amount of work on
understanding reinforcement learning as
essentially a special case of a broader
set of loss functions
and how preference orientation in the
extreme becomes reinforcement learning
and then an epistemic value term can be
added that takes an algorithm beyond
just pursuing reward. And also that's
kind of independently originated in meta
reinforcement learning or all these
other kind of flavors offshooting. So
especially by taking more of a yes and
posture to looking at what's out there,
we can see that there are just seeds of
this framework in work already that's
happening. And then A25 is I guess the
bottom of that page um on on page 396.
That's where you can draw what's next.
But we'll get there in a couple months,
I think. So, any more comments on
appendix A or any specific questions
like raise your hand and ask. Otherwise,
please familiarize yourself with how to
add questions to the table because
they'll make a huge mark if you write a
question here or if you pop into
something else that someone wrote and
add it there.
Hey, Daniel.
>> Hey, Carrie. Please go for it.
>> Um, I wrote a comment in the chat. Um, I
don't have I haven't used it the the
online um thing yet. Um, but I was
noticing Sanji's use of intrinsic and
exttrinsic rewards in the section on
reinforcement learning and just wanted
to understand the context of those
specific terms in contrast to epistemic
and pragmatic
um that I've heard in other active
inference circles. So
>> that's a great question. Thank you.
Yeah, on a first pass, exttrinsic value
is pragmatic value, intrinsic value is
epistemic value, but intrinsic value
might be a bit broader because it might
not just refer to learning. However, at
a first pass, exttrinsic and intrinsic
value is more from the domain of
reinforcement learning
and epistemic and pragmatic value is a
specific decomposition of a form of the
expected free energy functional.
So in that decomposition of expected
free energy,
pragmatic and epistemic do map to
exttrinsic and intrinsic
but there are other partitions of how to
think about free energy functionals.
So I hope that is accurate and we can
add more connections there.
Yeah, the
>> maybe really quickly, Carrie, that all
of those terms are quite big terms and
important terms in the in the literature
and as as Daniel said, and they do get
um elaborated further on and throughout
the book indeed. So, uh they won't be
bandied about quite so
I don't want to say carelessly, but they
will be carefully unpacked uh for sure
as we as we go along. Yeah.
Yeah, it's they they have a lot of
there's definitely at least a loose
association between how they're used in
different places. And as far as like the
equation that you you pointed to there
in the appendix like 8.8
um epistemic value there generally does
align with where we see it anywhere
else. And then um here he's saying that
it equals predictive mutual information.
And that that both simpl that both adds
to and takes away from the confusion
around it cuz it's like it simplifies it
because it's like oh we're just saying
that they equal each other. Um you'll
see that very often like one term or
equation with just a little bit of
changing things around suddenly can
equal another useful term. Um but then
on the other hand like we can start to
get kind of lost in like what equals
what still or if something is being uh
subtracted from something else rather
than equals something else. But yeah so
here epistemic value is just sort of
saying like what's the difference in
what you believe about um what your
actions can do the the pi the the
conditioning on pi um your beliefs about
what your actions can do in relation to
states. Um, but the the difference is
whenever you add the O, so it's like,
oh, what did I think I could do to
impact the world versus what do I think
I can do to impact the world given that
I just saw new information to to make
that update. And so that's kind of if
this term here is being used in the
context of like learning um then then
yeah it would it would be about just
doing the typical you you get some new
data some new O's and then you update
your beliefs about about the world and
what you can do in it. I hope that
that's simple enough to kind of follow.
>> Yeah. intrinsic rewards and their
necessary innovation in machine learning
and coercion of curiosity into a reward
framework is sort of like in a way now
from sitting here it's like the limits
of reward-based learning. It's like well
yeah you can coersse curiosity and these
other features into reward. You can make
some conversion factor between curiosity
or some other feature to reward.
Why not just work with this broader
functional that has a decomposible
element
which can be with different
decompositions that capture different
features of what are called intrinsic
and exttrinsic rewards but the the space
of the different decompositions is very
rich. Okay, let's go to chapter one.
Um few different ways to look at this in
terms of one one which is the
dependencies of the different ideas in
the flow.
Figure one two with understanding three
kind of settings that sometimes even
within a sentence a person or a book
will flip between where we have the
hypothesis testing scientist.
The generic agent in the niche could be
a body, it could be uh whatever some
sort of living form or some sort of
robotic form and then in its more
analytical representation just talking
about the generative model and the
generative process. So we can talk about
the scientist in the lab, scientist
actually dealing with their system of
interest.
Sometimes we use a more generic
ecological psychology or cybernetics
framing of agent and environment or
agent in the niche their synthesis.
And then other times if we're especially
directly pointing to just like the API
connections basically like what are the
variables in the equation what is the
logic flow on this program then we're
talking more about the generative model
and the generative process which also
helps clarify and forestall a sort of
map territory conflation which has been
brought up and higher order critiques
brought up thereof. But generative model
and generative process makes it really
clear that we're looking at maps of
territories or what Toby Sinclair Smith
calls the compositional cognitive
cgraphy mapmaking. We're talking about
the map most clearly in the bottom row
here.
Whereas sometimes talking about real
systems
can be helpful in that it's intuitive
and it can result unintentionally in
conflation of this realism
instrumentalism debate.
And here's looking at using the middle
rows ontology of agent and environment.
But again, you can kind of put that you
could step into that driver's seat and
think about this as like the person or
the scientist or the textbook reader in
the groove. Or you could kind of step
out of even agent and niche and you
could think about this like a more
generic physics of intelligent
interfaces with this connection between
the generative process and the
generative model where there's some
process out there out of bounds and then
there's some bounded agent system which
is described with a generative model.
Now in certain situations people will
use generative model to describe their
total understanding of the dependencies
of the whole system.
Here generative model is specifically
describing the kind of bounded system of
interest to the exclusion of the
generative process which is external to
the agent.
Um, so any like thoughts on that or a
part of chapter 1 that somebody wants to
go to or any other idea?
>> Yeah, Fraser then anyone to raise their
hand.
only to say that this notion of
generative process and generative model
is maybe the most fundamental idea in
all of active inference or at least the
most fundamental thing to to really try
and gro and understand. This is kind of
the atomic uh you know most basic thing
that sets up everything else in active
inference. So it is it is a very very
fundamental idea. I just want to kind of
you know make known its its significance
to to the entire idea about what active
inference is at all. So if you don't
understand it it's it's a very good uh
time to to really try and grock what
this what the distinction is between
this model and this process.
Yeah.
Again just raise your hand if you want
to make a point but let's look at this
dependency chart.
So we start off with this sort of
thought experiment taken to a slightly
deeper level than the merely qualitative
by this kind of brain in a vat or a
variety of other similar scenarios where
it's like what if you only had access to
you know oh what if what if you only had
access to observation states and what if
you could only act through a limited set
of actuators for example which is common
to teleoperation of a robot or of a
first person drone or of possibly a body
or of a digital agent things like that.
So it's like if we were going to learn
from the principles of the low energy
adaptive flexible general strategies
that we know of from the brain and the
mind
that's what Sanjie calls the box
scenario in in one two which is uh
citing some work by Daniel Dennett. So
Hofetter and Dennit in that sort of '7s,
'8s, '90s periods, they made a lot of
influential
framing and thought experiments and
philosophies about essentially cognitive
modeling and philosophy, strange loops,
all that. And taking it in the other
direction from the box scenario,
there is this theory and practice of
empirical modeling and of doing
statistics and of doing model selection,
iterated modeling, model adequacy,
representations in scientific models,
realism and instrumentalism, map
territory, all these kinds of
strategies. So whether we're modeling
ourself
in terms of this like reflexive agent or
we're choosing a modeling strategy for
another agent like our vacuum robot or a
bird outside or an ant colony or
something like that, we converge to this
generic setting which is like there's
going to be figure and ground. There's
going to be thing and surrounding.
There's going to be stage and offstage.
And what's so interesting about that
unity is plural and at minimum too is
like if you don't have that, you don't
have a thing you're talking about. And
for whatever thing you're talking about,
you implicitly or explicitly, whether as
a known unknown or as an unknown
unknown, have something that is excluded
by what that thing's definition is. So
that kind of takes us into this theory
of everything
direction that free energy principle and
basian mechanics gets to. But again,
it's like whether we're going to model a
dust particle and we're going to have
passive brownian diffusion or we're
going to have a stock with a sort of
stochastic walk. We're going to have a
multi- aent situation of cyberphysical
or biological entities or we're just
going to pull back into that more
generic setting of generative model and
generative process. We converge upon
this idea that there's going to be a
process on one side of a of a boundary,
processes on the other side of a
boundary, and then a birectional
interface between them.
Those
could be on like essentially different
wavelengths. Like you could make a model
where the the room has a temperature
that changes and the agent is just
imagining what colors it's going to wear
tomorrow. There's nothing wrong with
that. Like there doesn't have to be a
match between what the agent is
parameterizing or working through and
what's happening on the other side of
the boundary. Doesn't have to be. But if
you want to get into adaptive behavior,
you're going to get into situations
where like the reference is the same,
which takes us into like semiotics and
bioiotics. But that's more of a
situation where there is a temperature
in the room and then there's going to be
some representation of temperature by
the agent. The agent could have a
different type of representation of
temperature than in the room. But if
we're going to understand adaptive
behavior and temperature regulation and
temperature perception, we're kind of
like we're staying within the
temperature zone.
And in that situation, you have [snorts]
the generative process being in this
kind of thermostat example, the
temperature in the room, the real
changes that are happening in the
temperature of the room which are
unobserved directly. Then you have a
thermostat agent. So it's going to make
some kind of observations
of temperature. It could be a noisy
thermometer, could be a vertical
thermometer, and then it's going to do
some cognitive processing, could be
simple thresholding, it could be moving
average, it could be a Coleman filter.
Those are kind of the plug-andplay
hot swappable cognitive elements. And
then it's going to output decisions or
actions to actuators. could be turn on
the air conditioner or the heater and
that's going to close the loop with the
environment. Part of the fun and the
open-endedness of the framework is like
it doesn't have to describe any
particular situation.
So it doesn't describe any particular
situation. We don't want it to describe
any particular situation. So there can
be all these pedagogical or fantastical
contrived situations like the agent is
perceiving temperature and has a strong
preference but its actions are
completely non secular.
You can design that situation. So
there's nothing about this articulation
that is about anything in particular.
Literally, it's not about anything in
particular, but it's about things in
particular. And then you make specific
generative models as an embodied
practice
that can then be tested, falsified,
assessed for adequacy and relevance and
things like that.
So that's what this chapter does is kind
of look at that thought experiment
branch
and then a little bit more about this
kind of figure and ground agent and
niche branch where one side or both
sides are making representations of each
other for action especially
and then from this
predicament
which is that something about the states
of the environment are to be inferred.
Not necessarily to 50 decimal points of
accuracy for no particular reason, but
essentially what people might call
actionable intelligence
for fitness and and adaptation.
You are beset with needing to do some
kind of generic computation to
understand how should the agents update
its beliefs and update its actions.
When new observations come in, noisy as
they may be, indirect as they may be,
what happens? And that is sometimes
what's referred to as change your mind,
change the world, where a new
observation comes in. And the autonomous
states, which are the states that are
under the agent's control, it's belief
states, which can be updated and action
states, which action states, which
result in some type of action selection.
those may be updated by incoming
observation. So that's the sort of like
crucible of the situation being studied
is there's a configured setting and an
observation is going to cross an
interface and there's going to be some
possibility of updating of internal
cognitive states
whether from just what temperature do I
believe it is given the thermometer all
the way up on through more hierarchical
narrative type states and Then what is
the action outcome? And again you can
make an example where there's belief
updating but the actions are always
chosen by flipping a coin randomly or
something like that. So it's not that it
must be any certain way but it's like
the Lego environments that we can talk
about it as every plausible way.
Okay. Yes. Thank you for that. I'll I'll
copy that question in.
Um, does the environ uh c can the
environment
also include other potential agents
such that external states would be
internal states of other agents?
Short answer, yes. [snorts] Like
thinking about this video conversation
like someone's sensory perimeter is not
being perforated for going on Zoom
directly right from a material and
energy exchange but there are other
individuals that are using their actions
to modify your sensory states and then
you can say what did this person mean
but that is still internal to the
sensory boundary and I'm sure we will
revisit and nuance this but it is not
simply like the sensory epithelial
of the organism is its boundary
but just at a first pass the sensory
states are mapped onto the perceptive
apparatus the action states are mapped
on to the actuators Mark
Yes. Let's see if I can formulate this
question. So, uh I I like this. This is
very clear in terms of looking at how an
agent with a model would model external
states in the environment if I'm if I'm
doing that and adapt to those states as
they change or at least make inferences
for uh from which they can adapt.
What I'm wondering is, and and this
probably has to do with where you draw
your boundaries and your your so-called
Markoff blankets, is if the agent has a
mind change or a a a shift in internal
states that's independent of the
environment, are you just casting your
model uh boundary or your blanket
um in a different place? So let's say I
I'm sitting here and independent of
what's going on around me. I decide or I
recall something.
Uh I decide to take an action or I have
a recollection. So I'm kind of making
maybe that's in intraception, right? I'm
making inferences about
something that is not necessarily
environmental. It may be triggered by
the environment. And I may see something
that helps me recall something. But it
may be uh you know example I'm I'm
asleep and I I dream and have a change
of an internal state that's uh
potentially devoid of the the external
environment. How how does that kind of
play out
if that question makes sense?
>> Yes. Lot to it. So one thing is like we
have the kind of single layer
calisthenics like single layer model
just looking at a simple reduced
situation and then when we get into like
mental travel
self-reflection meaning making all these
kinds of more um human or introspective
phenomena there isn't just going to be
one way but like part of the fun is your
question brings us to the Grand Canyon
and Then you can like propose different
models and explore how they're similar
or different. What would be the
situation that differentiates them? What
is the right way to model that kind of
like interior axis and interiority?
A note about markoff blankets is like a
blanket state is actually to to take a
deflationary or just sort of descriptive
approach to it. It's contingent upon the
choice of what node is the internal
node. The blanket states are the
parents. So the upstream causal
dependencies, the children which is the
downstream causal dependencies and the
co-parents which are co-parents of
downstream dependencies.
Selecting an internal node does not
change the computational or the
cognitive dynamics of the basian
network. So it's not like there are
nodes out there in the world. But even
if we're just talking about the map,
it's not that some node is a blanket
node. For example, even within
um like a a like
choosing a different node as internal
external sets what nodes are blanket
nodes. It's not that a node being
assigned as a blanket changes its
function at all. Um so where the
boundaries are drawn is essentially
unadressable until the node topology the
graph structure is drawn and once it is
drawn it's trivial given selection of
what node you want to select of it as
internal.
So that results in a lot of um
heat and and smoke and uh [laughter]
and and more
because it's not like a tagged or
assigned feature of the world. It's a
relative position to another observer
who's broken a symmetry on an existing
graph.
And that may sound a bit oblique. So I
hope it's not frontloading that topic
too much.
But the interface is interfacial because
we have selected the internal as
internal. But selecting another node is
internal would have resulted in a
different markoff blanket.
So it's not that we can describe for a
real system what nodes are blanket but
until we draw the generative model then
it becomes apparent.
Fraser then Andrew.
>> Yeah. Just really quickly I mean this
this is a this is an excellent
discussion. This is actually one of the
um frontiers in some sense of active
inference is what exactly constitutes
the environment. We have this agent and
then we have this idea of the
environment and there's a lot of very
interesting work going on in that. I'm
actually doing I'm privileged to be
participating in that work but I should
emphasize or remind everyone that it's
not you know that that discussion can
get very complex very quickly. Um, when
we're setting out to learn about the
foundations of active inference, all
that we need to know is that there is an
agent and it can interact with
something, some other thing. And that
some other thing is the environment. And
it can be anything. It can be another
agent. It can be physics. It can be
whatever. But we can think about it. We
can model it. We can uh parcel off all
of that complexity in our mind and just
say this is this is a thing. This is an
environment. Uh, and we don't have to
worry too much about what that means
yet. I can send actions to it and I can
get observations from it and that's
about all you need to know for quite a
long time before any well a lot of the
the hair questions and active inference
come up. So if you're feel if you're
feeling confused I I would uh counsel
you to not worry about any of these
questions just yet although there is a
lot of very fruitful discussion to be
had about them. That's all I wanted to
say on that point.
>> Cool. I'll also try to be kind of brief.
if we're getting like a really nice
holistic uh kind of take on this on this
question for the moment because it's
like we we have the basian network
perspective and and and all the rest.
So, um I I just really like the example
of thinking about like dreams um in that
here whenever we have folks who are who
are approaching active inference more
theoretically and thinking about how to
apply it in their own work whenever they
don't necessarily yet know um sort of
all the the the kind of network graph
level understanding and representations
of it all. Um, if you think of sort of
the the internal states of the agent as
being like necessarily independent of
the external states and then you think
of these kind of blanket states as both
the the the sensory information coming
into the agent and the the action or
control states uh coming out of the
agent like the policies they choose and
act upon. So it's kind of like this is
your inputs and your outputs, right? So
we can think about it a little bit
mathematically, right? like the inputs
and outputs to to a function. Something
comes in, some kind of change happens,
something comes out. It's kind of like
receive sensory information, update
internal states, and then output a new
action. And so here with dreaming, uh,
in reference to the the phrasing of the
question, dreaming is like well at that
whenever the agent is dreaming, they're
receiving sensory information. It's just
as we know it's being generated uh
almost almost entirely by their their
brain itself, right? Almost in the sense
of like a hallucination as opposed to
coming like genuinely externally. So
they're still receiving sensory
information. We're so we still have the
same kind of setup. um it'll be up to
the agent to kind of be able to have a
representation of of what it means to be
asleep versus awake so that the agent
could distinguish, oh well, that was
sensory information I received while I
was asleep. So that can mean very that
that that means I I should evaluate it
very differently from information I
would evaluate while I'm awake, right?
But if you have an agent who can't
distinguish between the two, which
starts to looking much more like a kind
of a pathological or potential
psychiatric uh issue in the cases of
someone who might experience um
hallucinations,
it starts looking very similar, right?
It's difficult to distinguish. Um but
but the setup is still sort of the same.
So I hope that was a lot longer than
what I meant to say, but uh I hope that
that was maybe a little more useful
context.
>> Thank you.
Yeah, let's again let's speedrun the
section headers on chapter one and then
anyone else who who hasn't um h had any
um questions can can ask it or we'll
review the questions. So we start with
hypothesis testing brain one one
introduces us to model and
representation map territory whether
that's agent in the niche or the
scientist and their system of interest
or this more generic situation with a
generative model and the generative
process.
There is the challenge or the
predicament of making sense of order in
that situation where it may be known or
unknown or knowable or unknowable or
cognitive constraints all these kind of
factors that make those observations on
Plato's cave or whatever it is on the
thermometer or on the plane those
observations can be quite distal or
lagged in time or causally different
than something that's upstream that's
causing them, which would be the sort of
ideal representation to work on in
certain situations.
And that's that thought experiment like
what what would you tell the Roomba
vacuum if it's going to go into a new
environment?
What you'd want to tell that is like in
a way is this book. That is the
environment agent
articulation figure and grounds
13 goes into bay updating. Generally
speaking, last names for scientific
terminology are not so descriptive. But
base theorem describes updating and the
kind of estuary like confluence of prior
beliefs with new observations
ranging from disregarding prior beliefs
and just snapping beliefs to the new
observation or disregarding
observations, no attention and just
rolling with your prior beliefs. or a
whole rainbow in between with a lot of
nuance about how and where and why and
when you update to modulate your beliefs
as information comes in. And the
terminology in equation
11 one
with the posterior belief
being what you believe or what the agent
believes after the observation comes in
is the posterior And it's composed of as
the prior which is what is believed
before the observation comes in
multiplied by the likelihood of that
evidence coming in divided by the
evidence of the model or as one of my
professors in undergrad called it the
dirty south because that is the
challenging part of the model sometimes
to model which leads to the sort of in
principle
sufficient
of B theorem. But in practice,
especially in computationally limited
setting or large state spaces,
the need to do probably approximately
correct computation
and specifically in the situation of the
inverse problem which is in 14 and the
statistical inverse problem is on the
top of page 15. Given some sensory data,
can the agent invert the information to
determine the most likely state that
generated the data it observed? And
sometimes those two directions are
described of as the tale of two
densities, a paper of that name, where
going from latent states to observables
is called a generative direction and
going from observables to likely states
is a recognition direction. So we can
think about generative AI as having this
like latent state space that's
generating tokens, generating outputs
from a state space and then also a
return direction that's recognizing
latent
environments
from incoming observations. And then
those 15 and 16, those six questions,
those are awesome questions. Like
five, how does the agent confirm its
guess about the nature of the
environment is correct? Or six, what
does the agent do if it turns out the
inverse problem is complex and
intractable? Like those are questions
that we will visit and revisit in active
101, 2011, 301, 401. It just comes again
and again with circling around,
spiraling around those kinds of
situations.
And then 1.5 closes with a little bit
more of a historical view on Helmhold's
perception as unconscious inference
and
a look towards the rest of the chapters
which um in that last paragraph it
appears the basian perspective on brain
computation basian brain may help an
agent solve the inverse problem. We will
come to see there are many mathematical
issues that arise when we extend the
model into these more complex situations
and our approach going forward in the
following chapters will be to explore
the computational underpinnings of
active inference.
So that's kind of that's the uh
that's the jump moment for the book.
It's like you read the intro and the
sort of more personal genre. We reviewed
appendix A, talked a little bit about
the history and kind of the upstream and
that little blank section on that last
page for the future where you can draw
something cool. And the rest of the book
is going to be kind of like a
bathtub dive into
a mainline development
which is summarized in
the introduction.
The mainline development is chapters
two, three, and to an extent four. Once
you get to four, you'll notice that that
is basically always going to be a
dependency.
So one is like a conceptual primer and
just introduces us to basian thinking
and the kind of qualitative thought
experiment that motivates
the agent needs situation.
The need to infer latent representations
from noisy sensor data. the challenge of
that inverse and forward problem
variational methods as being proposed
but not really described as a way to
tractably address it in this
biologically plausible setting. Then
we're just going to have two
get layered onto our stack hidden state
estimation.
We're going to have three layered onto
our stack with learning and inference
which is kind of like thinking fast and
slow like a faster flow like a neural
network
flow forward and more of a training.
It's not exactly that but it's like a
faster and a slower inference time
scale. And then four, which is funny
because the 2022 book, chapter 4, was
also sort of the um
big hunk there. But four is where we get
to variational inference. And then from
there, there's a couple of like kind of
secondary excursions. Like here we have
predictive coding leading to 678
and then we sort of pull back to the
palm DP.
The palm DP is built upon in 10. So 678
and then 910 are like two little
separate excursions.
And then part three largely builds on
part two and closes with a bit more of a
landing strip and a first principles
look towards back on the book and
towards the second book.
Um
if there's any other question please
raise your hand. Thank you. Um for for
those who are like following along and
and writing everything in the time
between,
please feel free to write questions,
open up what other people wrote.
It's not a closed book. So jump in,
leave an emoji, write a question, make
your own kod if you want to play around
with just like the kod tooling or get
familiar with it or email uh blanket
atactiveinference.institute institute if
you just have written up stuff
and um yeah
join
Andrew and Frasier's session upcoming on
one and then again we're going to settle
down
um uh Mark find that section two ways in
to the questions one is just to go to
the chapter where it's filtered by the
chapter already
or you can go to the overall questions
table which has all of them and you can
also search for stuff with that
that search bar on the top left. One
cool feature
is um that that they just added that's
kind of fun is like here's the table for
all the figures, but then also you can
click on these different views
So that's kind of cool. Gives us some
different views and maybe we'll use that
for equations and other stuff.
All right.
Thank you for chapter 1 and appendix A.
Staying on those two for this week and
more and difference in the future.
Bye.